la gauche qui ne concrétise pas dans le
canton de trappes malgré son avance du
premier tour les verts qui ne
parviennent pas à faire de rambouillet
le premier canton écologistes des
yvelines le rassemblement national qui
subit de lourdes défaites à bonnières
sur seine et à mantes la jolie pour la
majorité sortante les bonnes nouvelles
se sont multipliées dimanche soir
certaines meilleures que d'autres avec
dans plusieurs cantons de véritable
plébiscite apprécié par exemple karl
olive et suzanne john hayes récolte plus
de 70% des suffrages
large victoire également de la majorité
sortante à aubergenville chatou limay
saint germain en laye sartrouville ou
encore versailles 1 et versailles 2 le
chêne et rocquencourt et saint cyr
l'école
la stratégie de pierre bédier payante a
été payante c'est à dire un centre un
centre est et une droite ouverte puisque
nos candidats n'étaient pas forcément et
l'air était privé d'un modem avec des
stages au vermont remplaçants sur le
canton de 2003 sacyr et bois d'arcy qui
est jean baptiste à munich
donc la stratégie était plutôt payante
c'est à dire une stratégie ouverte une
stratégie pas forcément fermé sur sur
des étiquettes politiques
on aura travaillé jusqu'au bout parce
que les électeurs lui ai promis d'être
là comme l'ours avant de l'avoir fini at
dans d'autres cantons les succès de la
droite et du centre sont moins
importants laissant des regrets à leurs
adversaires qu'il s'agisse des mureaux
de conflans sainte honorine ou de
plaisir voire de montigny le bretonneux
on est déçu pour pour les habitants
effectivement
parce que pas ce qu'on a rencontrés en
tout cas ils y croyaient ils ont voté
pour nous donc je pense qu'il y à une
mouvance effectivement qui est en train
de naître de remettre
et voilà il faut attendre peut-être
quelques temps pour que de nouveaux
puissent identifier une vraie gauche si
sauf quand on n'a pas vraiment douté
parce qu'on a fait une campagne où c'est
vraiment donner à fond et on a essayé de
retranscrire toute la
le bonheur est en tout cas l'envi que
l'on avait pas après c'est évident
qu'avec ce taux d'abstention là c'est
toujours compliqué on sait pas trop
comment les choses vont tourner mais on
était confiant sûr j'avais encore une
fois on a un bilan solide
on avait une envie on a fait beaucoup de
choses je pense que on est très heureux
on avait dit que le canton de montigny
guyancourt comme de deux autres étaient
sans doute fragile et et pouvait
basculer ça n'a pas été le cas et au
contraire on a fait un score extrêmement
fort donc pour nous c'est évidemment une
très grande joie et je salue aussi
mon candidat qui était en face de moi
françois morton parce qu'on a je crois a
essayé de faire une campagne extrêmement
digne et respectueuse et on était
d'ailleurs régulièrement au téléphone
ensemble pour essayer de caler les
choses et c c'est bien de pouvoir faire
des élections de cette façon là est de
montrer cette façon de faire les choses
allaient de la politique auprès des
habitants la droite et le centre réalise
donc un nouveau grand chelem avec
vingt-et-une victoires sur 21 possibles
mais de nouveaux visages si elles seront
néanmoins dans l'hémicycle qu'il
s'agisse de julien chambon sur wii ou
encore de fabienne duwez à verneuil sur
seine et de grégory gars restiez à
maurepas en 2014 je m'étais engagé
auprès de mes électeurs auprès des
habitants de vos repas les moyens de ne
pas cumuler deux mandats parce que
c'était mon premier mandat de maire et
parce que j'estime également que je si
je devais faire mes preuves je devais
m'impliquer pleinement aussi dans ma vie
mais ce sera toujours le cas dans les
années qui viennent et je me suis aperçu
avec l'expérience maintenant que le
mandat de conseiller départemental
c'est le prolongement du mandat de maire
c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est la
proximité et le terrain le mandat de
conseil départemental c'est des
compétences de proximité